हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में बताइए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? यस या
नो? प्लीज चैट में बताइए।
शायद क्लास में कोई आया ही नहीं।
जगत गुरु जी मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
आपको?
आई एम ऑडिबल।
ओके थैंक यू कल्पेश चौधरी एंड थैंक यू जगत
गुरु जी एंड थैंक यू लक्स
35 थैंक यू आप लोगों ने रिस्पांस किया
बिकॉज़ मुझे लगा कि मेरी आवाज सुनाई नहीं
दे रही सबको
थैंक यू माय टीम
तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं स्टूडेंट तो अभी
तक आए नहीं है लेकिन जो स्टूडेंट प्रेजेंट
है प्लीज आप मुझे यह बता दीजिए कि
प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने स्कोपिंग डिस्कस
की थी या प्रिपेयरिंग फोर्स अटैक में तो
क्या वो चीज क्लियर आपको समझ में आ गया था
उससे रिलेटेड कोई भी डाउट है आपका तो
प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए
कोई भी कैसा भी डाउट आपका
क्योंकि अभी धीरे-धीरे नहीं हम थ्योरी से
प्रैक्टिकल पे भी जाना स्टार्ट करेंगे ऐसा
नहीं कि मैं थ्योरी ही पढ़ाऊंगा आपको नहीं
धीरे-धीरे हम प्रैक्टिकल पे जाना स्टार्ट
करेंगे अभी क्योंकि
आपका फंडामेंटल बेस तैयार करने के बाद मैं
हमेशा प्रैक्टिकल पे ही जाता हूं। तो अभी
धीरे-धीरे हम बीच में प्रैक्टिकल्स कर
करेंगे क्योंकि जैसा कि मैंने क्लास 60
में बताया था आप लोगों को एक टॉपिक
ओवरव्यू दिया था कि हम अपकमिंग क्लासेस
में किन-किन चीजों के बारे में डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं और क्या-क्या बात करने वाले
हैं, क्या-क्या पढ़ने वाले हैं। वो सारी
चीजें मैंने आपको बताई थी। तो पहले वो
कंप्लीट करेंगे। उसके बाद हम अपने नेक्स्ट
किसी एक्शन पेन टेस्टिंग के टॉपिक पर
जाएंगे।
तो किसी का कोई डाउट नहीं है। मुझे लगता
है शायद कोई डाउट नहीं है इसलिए आप लोग
मुझसे कुछ पूछ नहीं रहे।
ओके। Google से डाउट क्लियर कर लेते हो।
Google से डाउट क्लियर हो जाते हैं।
ओके और बाकी सेशन में मजे आ रहे हैं या
बोरिंग लग रहा है या बस ओनली प्रैक्टिकल
का वेट कर रहे हो बताओ
चलिए सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो इतने
ही स्टूडेंट आते हैं हमारी क्लास में।
इससे ज्यादा तो आते नहीं मुझे पता है।
चलिए अगेन बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज लाउड
एंड क्लियर है। तो मैं अभी पीपीटीज पर
चलता हूं अपनी।
चलो आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक है वो है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल।
तो हम डिस्कस करेंगे कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक साइकिल होती क्या है? कितने टाइप्स
की होती है? और क्यों जरूरत पड़ी? और सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग जो अटैक साइकिल है वह नॉर्मल
फेंटेस्टिंग फेज से डिफरेंस डिफरेंट क्यों
है? इस पे हम बात करने वाले हैं। ओके? तो
सबसे पहले हम कंपेयर करेंगे। ठीक है?
हमारी स्टैंडर्ड पेन टेस्टिंग फेज वर्सेस
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। स्टैंडर्ड पेन टेस्टिंग
फेज वर्सेस सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। सबसे पहले
जो उस पे बात करेंगे जो आपको पता है या इस
सवाल का जवाब हम ढूंढने की कोशिश करेंगे।
व्हाई सोशल इंजीनियरिंग रिक्वायर्स ए
डिफरेंट अटैक लाइफ साइकिल?
इफ यू आस्क एन एथिकल हैकर और पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर टू एक्सप्लेन देयर टिपिकल अटैक
मेथोडोलॉजी दे विल यूजुअली डिस्क्राइब द
स्टैंडर्ड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग लाइफ
साइकिल दैट वी डिस्कस्ड इन द अर्लियर
केसेस क्लासेस मतलब अगर आप किसी एक एथिकल
हैकर सिक्योरिटी टेस्टर्स या पेन टेस्टर
से पूछोगे कि उनका अटैक प्रोसेस क्या होता
है या जब वह अटैक करते हैं वो कौन सी
टेक्न टेक्निक्स या मेथडोलॉजीस का यूज
करते हैं तो उनका नॉर्मल जवाब होता है या
हर किसी का जवाब वही होगा। वह पांच या छह
स्टैंडर्ड स्टेप्स के बारे में बताएंगे जो
हम अपनी प्रीवियस क्लासेस में ऑलरेडी
डिस्कस चुके कर चुके हैं। सबको पता होगा
कि हम प्रीवियस क्लासेस में ऑलरेडी डिस्कस
कर भी चुके हैं। जैसे कि हमें पता है
स्टैंडर्ड पेन टेस्टिंग मेथोड जैसे रिकॉन
हो गया जिसको हम इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग
स्टेज भी बोलते हैं। फज़ टू स्कैनिंग एंड
एनुमरेशन फज़ थ्री गेनिंग एक्सेस जिसको हम
एक्सप्लइटेशन फज़ बोलते हैं। मेंटेनिंग
एक्सेस पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन फज़ इनके बारे
में हम काफी डिटेल में बात कर चुके हैं।
हमारी पुरानी क्लासेस में क्लियरिंग
ट्रैक्स, रिमूविंग एविडेंस या रिपोर्टिंग
जिसके बारे में हमने अभी तक बात नहीं
किया। ये कुछ छह से पांच से छह स्टेप्स
होते हैं। पांच से छह स्टैंडर्ड फेजेस बोल
सकते हो जो हर कोई पेन टेस्टर्स या हर कोई
सिक्योरिटी टेस्टर्स आपको बताएगा जब भी आप
उससे पूछोगे कि आपकी जो एक नॉर्मल पेन
टेस्टिंग मेथोलॉजी क्या होती है या आपका
अटैक प्रोसेस क्या है? जब अगर आपको किसी
के ऊपर अटैक करना है तो दीज़ मेथडोलॉजीस
वर्क्स एक्सट्रीमली वेल फॉर ट्रेडिशनल
टेक्निकल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग्स। बेसिकली
अगर आप कोई टेक्निकल पेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग कर
रहे हो जैसे किसी सिस्टम की, किसी सर्वर्स
की या किसी मशीन की, उस केस में यह जो पेन
टेस्टिंग मेथोडोलॉजीस हैं, यह जो
टेक्निक्स हैं, यह फेजेस हैं वेरी वेल।
एक्सट्रीमली वेल। दे आर वेरी एनफ। दे आर
वेरी वेरी गुड। क्योंकि यही एक स्टैंडर्ड
है। यही ज्यादा सभी लोग यही फॉलो करते
हैं। ऑफेंसिव रेटिमर्स कोई भी है चाहे वह
आपका ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स है एनीवन इन द
वर्ल्ड सभी इन्हीं पे टेस्टिंग मेथडोलॉजीस
का यूज करते हैं। तो उनके लिए जो
ट्रेडिशनल आपके टेक्निकल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग है उनके लिए यह क्या है? बेस्ट
है। अभी आते हैं हम सोशल इंजीनियरिंग पर।
ठीक है? तो हाउएवर व्हेन इट कम्स टू सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग दी स्टैंडर्ड टेक्निकल फेस नो
लगर फिट परफेक्टली। लेकिन जब बात आती है
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की वहां पर यह जो
स्टैंडर्ड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
मेथोडोलॉजीस है या जो स्टैंडर्ड टेक्निकल
फेजेस हैं ये फिट नहीं बैठते वहां पर।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के केस में यह परफेक्टली
फिट नहीं बैठते। क्यों नहीं बैठते? बिकॉज़
इन ए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट द टारगेट
इज नॉट ए फायरवॉल एन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और ए
वलनेबल सॉफ्टवेयर। द टारगेट इज ए इज द
ह्यूमन माइंड। मेरे कहने का मतलब क्या है?
यहां पर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स में जो
आपका टारगेट है वह कोई फायर वॉल, कोई
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स या कोई आउटडेटेड
सॉफ्टवेयर नहीं है। बल्कि हमारा टारगेट
कौन है? एक इंसानी दिमाग है, ह्यूमन ब्रेन
है, ह्यूमन बीइंग है या ह्यूमन माइंड है
जिनको हम बोल सकते हैं। ठीक है? इंसान
हमारा टारगेट है। इसलिए जो हमारी
स्टैंडर्ड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जो फेजेस
हैं, जो टेक्निकल फेजेस हैं, यह रिकॉन है,
स्कैनिंग एनमरेशन है, गेनिंग एक्सेस है,
मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस है, क्लियरिंग ट्रैक्स
है या रिपोर्टिंग है। इनमें से बहुत सारे
जो फेजेस हैं, वह क्या है? फिट नहीं बैठते
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के केस में। तो फिर क्या
फीडबैठ है उसके ऊपर भी बात करेंगे। तो एन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कैन बी सिक्यर्ड बाय
इंस्टॉलिंग सिक्योरिटी पैचेस। ए फायर वॉल
कैन बी रिकॉन्फ़िगर्ड एंड ए सॉफ्टवेयर
वनेबिलिटी कैन बी फिक्स्ड थ्रू अपडेट। अब
एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को पैच किया जा सकता
है। उसके सिक्योरिटी पैचेस को इंस्टॉल
करके एक फायर को वाल को रिकॉन्फ़िगर किया
जा सकता है। या फिर बात करें किसी एक
सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटी की उसको भी फिक्स
किया जाता है अपडेट करके। लेकिन बट ह्यूमन
बीइंग कैन नॉट बी पैच्ड इन द सेम वे।
लेकिन जब बात आती है इंसान की इंसान को
फायरवल किसी कंप्यूटरटर्स किसी सॉफ्टवेयर
की तरह पैच नहीं किया जा सकता। बल्कि
बल्कि द ओनली इफेक्टिव वे टू स्ट्रेंथ द
ह्यूमन एलिमेंट इज थ्रू अवेयरनेस, एजुकेशन
एंड कंटीन्यूअस सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग। एक
इंसान को पैच करने के लिए हमें क्या करना
पड़ता है? उसको एजुकेट करना पड़ता है।
उसको ट्रेनिंग देनी पड़ती है। उसको अवे
अवेयर करवाना पड़ता है सिचुएशन से। उसको
सिनेरियो एक्सप्लेन करने पड़ते हैं। सही
और गलत के बीच में फर्क बताना पड़ता है।
ऐसा हो गया तो क्या करना है और ऐसा नहीं
हुआ तो क्या करना है? ये सारे सिनेरियोस
ये सारी अवेयरनेस ये सारी जो ट्रेनिंग्स
हैं या जो सारी एजुकेशन है हमें एक ह्यूमन
बीइंग को पैच करने के लिए प्रोवाइड करनी
पड़ती है जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं कि
एजुकेशन देना उनको ट्रेनिंग देना ओके तभी
एक ह्यूमन बीइंग को किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
के अंदर पैच किया जा सकता है उनको क्या
किया जा सकता है
अपडेट किया जा सकता है तो नाउ
फॉर दिस रीजन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट
फॉलोस ए स्लाइटली मॉडिफाइड एंड
स्टैंडर्डाइज मेथडोलॉजी दैट फोकस ऑन
ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी रेदर देन टेक्निकल
वनेबिलिटीज। मतलब यह हुआ इसलिए हम क्या
करते हैं कि इंसान को पैच करने के लिए हम
एक स्लाइटली मॉडिफाइड और एक स्टैंडर्डाइज
फ्रेमवर्क का को फॉलो करना पड़ता है। उसको
हम फॉलो करते हैं
जिसको हम बोलते हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल। ओके?
हम क्या करते हैं कि जो नॉर्मल आपकी पेन
टेस्टिंग फ्रेमवर्क है उसको थोड़ा सा
मॉडिफाई करके थोड़ा सा स्टैंडराइज करके हम
क्या करते हैं? एक और फ्रेमवर्क यूज करते
हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक के केस में
जिसको हम बोल बोल सकते हैं सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल। इसमें टोटल
सात फेज होते हैं। फेज वन स्कोपिंग फेज।
फेज टू होता है आपका रिकॉर्न फेज ओपन
ओसेंट गैदरिंग। फेज थ्री होता है आपका
डिजाइन एंड अप्रूवल जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं
वेपनाइजिंग ओसेंट। जहां पर हम रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन करते हैं।
इंप्लीमेंटेशन
फेज फाइव डिटेक्शन जहां पर डिटेक्ट करना।
फेज सिक्स मेजरमेंट एंड फेज सेवन
रिपोर्टिंग। फेज सेवन रिपोर्टिंग।
अभी यह हर एक फेज का क्या मतलब है? किस
फेज में क्या होता है? क्या-क्या चीजें की
जाती है? हम अपनी दो क्लासेस में कवर
करेंगे। पहली आज की क्लास में हम कवर
करेंगे फेज वन टू एंड थ्री। पेज फेज नंबर
फोर, फाइव, सिक्स एंड सेवन हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में कवर करेंगे मे बी टुमारो। मे बी
टुमारो उस क्लास में हम कवर करेंगे। बिकॉज़
सैटरडे को मैं क्लास नहीं ले पाया था। तो
उसकी रिकवरी के लिए हम
99% चांसेस है कि मैं कल क्लास आपकी
लूंगा। उसकी अनाउंसमेंट आपको मिल जाएगी।
तो चलिए फिर लेट्स ब्रेक डाउन ईच स्टेप
सीक्वेंसली। हर एक स्टेप को स्टेप बाय
स्टेप हम क्या करते हैं? समझने की कोशिश
करते हैं। किस फेज में क्या होता है?
किस में? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ
साइकिल के अंदर। तो चलिए फिर बात करते हैं
फेज वन की स्कोपिंग फेज जो ऑलरेडी आप क्या
कर चुके हो कर चुके हैं जो स्कोपिंग फेज
आपका हमने प्रीवियस क्लासेस में डिस्कस कर
चुके हैं। प्रीवियस की दो क्लासेस में
हमने बहुत कुछ डिस्कस किया है और जिनमें
हमारा मेन फोकस था स्कोपिंग के ऊपर जहां
पर हमने स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क के बारे में
पढ़ा था। रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट के बारे में
पढ़ा था। बहुत सारे रियल वर्ल्ड केसेस
हमने यह भी देखा था कि अगर आपके
क्सिक्वेंसेस क्या होंगे स्कोपिंग फेज के
अगर आपने स्कोप डिस्कस नहीं किया तो वो
सारी चीजें हम ऑलरेडी क्या क्या कर चुके
हैं डिस्कस कर चुके हैं इसलिए जो फेज वन
है मैंने आपको क्या बताया था प्रिपेयरिंग
फॉर एन अटैक पार्ट वन एंड पार्ट टू
प्रीवियस के दो क्लासेस में वो क्या था
किसी अटैक की तैयारी करना तो उसमें सबसे
पहले क्या था फेज डिस्कस करना और आज मैंने
आपको क्या एक्सप्लेन कर रहा हूं सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल और उसमें भी
क्या है? फज़ वन स्कोपिंग फज़। तो अगर हमें
अटैक करना है तो हमें फेज वन तो करना ही
पड़ेगा। तो फेज वन क्या है? आपका स्कोपिंग
फज़। तो इसके बारे में आपको मैं क्या थोड़ा
सा ओवरव्यू फिर से दे देता हूं क्योंकि
कुछ स्टूडेंट्स अगर आज नए हैं तो क्या है?
उनको पता चल जाएगा। द टर्म स्कोपिंग
सिंपली मींस एस्टैब्लिशिंग द बाउंड्रीज,
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स एंड रूल्स ऑफ एन असेसमेंट
बिफोर एनी टेस्टिंग बिगिंस।
मतलब स्कोपिंग का सीधा मतलब है क्या करना
बाउंड्री सेट करना रूल सेट करना स्टेटमेंट
ऑफ वर्क एक कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन करना रूल्स
ऑफ इंगेजमेंट सेट करना साइन करना डिफाइन
करना उसका मतलब क्या है स्कोपिंग फज़
स्कोपिंग का मतलब यही होता है ड्यूरिंग
दिस फज़ द क्लाइंट एंड द सिक्योरिटी टीम सट
डाउन टुगेदर टू डिस्कस एव्री क्रिटिकल
डिटेल्स इन एडवांस इंश्योरिंग दैट देयर आर
नो मिस मिसअंडरस्टैंडिंग, लीगल
डिस्प्यूट्स और कंप्लायंस इशू लेटर इन द
इंगेजमेंट। मतलब जैसा कि मैं पहले बता
चुका हूं कि इसमें क्लाइंट और जो
सिक्योरिटी टीम है आमने-सामने बैठकर हर एक
उस पॉइंट पर बात करते हैं। हर एक उस
क्रिटिकल डिटेल्स पर बात करते हैं या
उन सारे सवालों और जवाबों पर बात करते हैं
जिनकी वजह से फ्यूचर में ड्यूरिंग
टेस्टिंग कोई लीगल प्रॉब्लम ना देखने को
मिले। जो सिक्योरिटी टीम्स है उसको कोई
लीगल क्सिक्वेंसेस या लीगल प्रॉब्लम का
सामना ना करना पड़े। जैसे कि
हु आर द ऑथराइज्ड टारगेट्स कि क्या हम
किसी भी मतलब टारगेट कौन हो सकते हैं
हमारे इन स्कोप क्या होगा? क्या हम किसी
भी एंप्लई को टारगेट कर सकते हैं या किसी
स्पेसिफिक डिपार्टमेंट को टारगेट करना है?
हु इज एक्स एक्सप्लसिटली आउट ऑफ स्कोप?
मतलब आउट ऑफ स्कोप में कौन है हमारे? क्या
हम कंपनी में सभी को टारगेट कर सकते हैं
या या हमें सी लेवल जो सीईओ है, सीएफओ है,
सीटीओ है क्या इनको हम अटैक कर सकते हैं?
नहीं कर सकते या यह हमारे आउट ऑफ स्कोप
है। या फिर हम बात करें वि अटैक चैनल्स आर
ऑथराइज्ड। हमारा अटैक का चैनल क्या होगा?
जैसे हमें फिशिंग अलाउड है, ओनली फिशिंग
अलाउड है या हम विशिंग का भी यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। स्मिंग का भी यूज कर सकते हैं या
दूसरी जो सोशल इंजीनिंग टैिक्स है उनका
यूज कर सकते हैं? नहीं कर सकते। व्हाट आर
द फिजिकल बाउंड्रीज ऑफ द असेसमेंट? फिजिकल
बाउंड्रीज क्या है? फिजिकल बाउंड्रीज से
मतलब क्या है? कि क्या मैं आपके ऑफिस
परमिसिस में यूएसबी ड्रॉप कर सकता हूं या
नहीं कर सकता? डमस्टर ड्राइविंग कर सकता
हूं या नहीं कर सकता? ये सारी चीजें हम
क्या करते हैं? डिस्कस करते हैं। और यह
ऑलरेडी बहुत ज्यादा डिटेल्स में मैं
प्रीवियस क्लास में बता चुका हूं। इस पे
मैं ज्यादा वह नहीं करने वाला। अभी
बहसबाजी नहीं करने वाला। तो नेक्स्ट अब
बात करते हैं इफ यू डू नॉट हैव ए क्लियरली
डिफाइंड रिटन स्कोप एंड ए साइन ऑथराइजेशन
फ्रॉम द क्लाइंट कंडक्टिंग एनी फॉर्म ऑफ
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग असेसमेंट इज कंसीडर्ड अन
ऑथराइज्ड एक्टिविटी मतलब यह है कि अगर
आपके पास कोई भी रिटर्न स्कोप या आपके पास
कोई भी साइन लेटर नहीं है साइन ऑथराइजेशन
नहीं है या आपके पास कोई कॉन्ट्रैक्ट नहीं
है यह अटैक करने के लिए तो
उस केस में क्या है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक करना इललीगल माना जाएगा। एक अन
ऑथराइज एक्टिविटी माना जाएगा। यह भी मैं
आपको बता चुका हूं। विदाउट प्रॉपर लीगल
ऑथराइजेशन सच एकशंस मे वायलेट द लॉ एंड
कुड रिजल्ट इन सीरियस लीगल क्सिक्वेंसेस।
अगर
आप ऐसा करोगे तो उससे क्या होगा? वायलेशन
होता है लॉ का जिसकी वजह से आपको जेल भी
जाना पड़ सकता है। जो मैं आपको बता भी
चुका हूं। तो यह कुछ नई चीज नहीं है।
इसलिए कहा जाता है कि नो स्कोप नो हो। एक
कहानी है। एक कहावत है साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में नो स्कोप। अगर स्कोप नहीं है तो कोई
उम्मीद भी मत रखना। मतलब अगर आपने स्कोप
डिफाइन नहीं किया है तो अपने प्रति आप रहम
की उम्मीद मत रखना। सीधी सी बात है। तो अब
बात करते हैं फेज टू रिकॉन फेज। ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस गैदरिंग। अब आते हैं हम किसके
ऊपर?
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस गैदरिंग के ऊपर या
रिकॉन फेज के ऊपर। दी ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑफ दिस
फेज इज टू डेवलप ए कंप्रहेंसिव
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ द टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
बिफोर एनी इंटरेक्शन विद इट्स एंप्लाइजज़
टेक प्लेस। इसके कहने का मतलब क्या है? कि
हम सबसे पहले क्या करते हैं? है रिकॉन फेज
में हम जो हमारी टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है
उसके ऊपर हम कंप्रहेंसिव रिसर्च करते हैं।
किसी भी इंडिविजुअल टारगेट को डायरेक्ट
इंटैक्ट करने से पहले टारगेट करने से पहले
उसके ऊपर पूरी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के ऊपर
कंप्रहेंसिव रिसर्च करते हैं। ईच एंड
एव्री डिटेल्स हम कलेक्ट करते हैं।
ड्यूरिंग दिस स्टेज एन एथिकल हैकर गैदर्स
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंटेलिजेंस अबाउट द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इंक्लूडिंग इट्स की पर्सनल
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्ट्रक्चर्स थर्ड पार्टी
वेंडर्स स्ट्रेटेजिक पार्टनर्स सप्लायर्स
बिजनेस प्रोसेससेस एंड टेक्नोलॉजीस
डिप्लॉयड विद इन इट्स एनवायरमेंट इस फेज
में हमारे टारगेट क्या होते हैं कंपनी के
की एंप्लाइजस होते हैं उनके वेंडर्स होते
हैं कौन-कौन से पार्टनर्स हैं सप्लायर्स
कौन-कौन है कंपनी में यूज होने वाली
टेक्नोलॉजी कौन सी है जो यूज़ हो रही है और
इन एडिशन वी आइडेंटिफाई द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
पब्लिक इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर सच एज इट्स
रजिस्टर्ड डोमेनस सब डोमेनस पब्लिकली
एक्सप्लोज्ड ईमेल एड्रेसेस और इसके अलावा
हम क्या करते हैं कंपनी के डोमेनस सब
डोमेनस ईमेल एड्रेसेस एंड मोस्टेंटली
इट्स कॉर्पोरेट ईमेल नेमिंग कन्वेंशन इट्स
कॉर्पोरेट
नेमिंग कन्वेंशन फॉर एग्जांपल फर्स्ट नेम
डॉट लास्ट नेम @ compनी डॉट और सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज क्या है? अगर आपको ईमेल का
जो स्टैंडर्ड ईमेल सिंटेक्स के बारे में
पता चल जाए कि जो कंपनी है उनका ईमेल
फॉर्मेट क्या है कि ज्यादातर वो किस
फॉर्मेट में ईमेल का यूज़ करते हैं जैसे
फर्स्ट नेम हो गया डॉट फिर लास्ट नेम@
compनी.com फॉर एग्जांपल nitesh.
Defonic.com अगर इस टाइप्स की ईमेल है
जैसे सचिन सिंह डॉट सॉरी अह
schin.@fonics.com
इस तरीके से अगर वह क्या कर रही हैं
सिंटेक्स का यूज़ कर रही हैं तो हो सकता है
कि
आपको
बहुत सारी चीजें आसान हो जाए। ठीक है?
बहुत सारी चीजें आसान हो जाए। क्योंकि
आपको क्लियरली पता चल गया स्वफ करने में
इजी हो जाएगा आपके लिए और आपको क्लियरली
पता चल गया कि हां इनका ईमेल पैटर्न क्या
है? ईमेल नेमिंग कन्वेंशन क्या है? उनका
स्टैंडर्ड ईमेल सिंटेक्स क्या है? जो
कंपनी फॉलो करती है। नेक्स्ट
व्हाई डू वी नीड टू आइडेंटिफाई कंपनीज़
वेंडर एंड सप्लायर्स?
अब आपका सवाल हो सकता है कि सर कंपनी के
वेंडर्स और सप्लायर्स का पता लगाने की
क्या जरूरत है? आवर असेसमेंट टारगेट इज द
कंपनी नॉट इट्स थर्ड पार्टी वेंडर्स। सर
हमारा टारगेट तो कंपनी है ना कि उनके थर्ड
पार्टी वेंडर्स। आप में से कोई लोग इसका
जवाब देना चाहेगा? एनीवन? कोई भी इसका
जवाब देना चाहेगा कि हम हमें जो कंपनी के
वेंडर्स और जो सप्लायर्स हैं उनके बारे
में पता लगाने की क्या जरूरत पड़ी? क्यों
जरूरत है? क्योंकि टारगेट वह नहीं है।
टारगेट हमारी कंपनी है। तो उनकी जरूरत
क्यों पड़ी? एनीवन वॉलंटियर
कोई है?
एक तो वैसे ही पांच स्टूडेंट हैं।
बताओ जरा कोई है वालंटियर
नोबडी
कोई इस सवाल का जवाब देना चाहेगा मैं सवाल
दोबारा रिपीट करता हूं कि मैंने आपको बोला
कि हमें एंप्लाइजज़ की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करनी है। उनके वेंडर्स, उनके
पार्टनर्स, सप्लायर्स, उनके टेक्नोलॉजी तो
हमें उनके वेंडर्स और सप्लायर्स के बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करने की क्या जरूरत
पड़ी?
ओके। जगत गुरु जी आप सही हो। थोड़ा सा और
इसकी एक्यूरेसी बढ़ाओ।
आप सही जा रहे हो। सही डायरेक्शन में जा
रहे हो। आंसर गलत नहीं है।
बिकॉज
पीपल ट्रस्ट व्हाट दे ऑलरेडी रिकॉग्नाइज।
मतलब लोग उन्हीं पर भरोसा करते हैं
जिन्हें वो पहले से जानते पहचानते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] समझ में आया?
लोग उन्हीं पर भरोसा करते हैं जिन्हें वह
पहले से जानते या पहचानते हैं। कभी भी
किसी भी अननोन व्यक्ति पर डायरेक्टली कभी
भी कोई भरोसा नहीं करता। चाहे मैं आप
इसमें मैं हूं, आप हो, कोई भी हो। एनीबडी
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अमन आप लोग बताओ प्राइस क्या डिसाइड करना
यार वेबिनार का?
आप लोग बता ही नहीं रहे वेबिनार का प्राइस
क्या है?
ओके। तो
ऐसा क्यों? मॉडर्न ऑर्गेनाइजेशन रेयरली
ऑपरेट इन आइसोलेशंस।
क्योंकि आजकल जितनी भी मॉडर्न
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है शायद ही कोई
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस होगी या शायद ही कोई
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कभी अकेले में ऑपरेट करती
होगी। अकेली ऑपरेट करती होगी। आइसोलेशन
एनवायरमेंट में ऑपरेट करती होगी। मतलब
किसी थर्ड पार्टी से संबंध नहीं रखती
होगी। शायद ही कोई ऑर्गेनाइजेशन होगी या
कभी कभार वह ऑपरेट करती होगी ऐसे
शायद ही। एंड एव्री कंपनी इंटक्ट डेली विद
पे रोल प्रोवाइडर्स, क्लाउड सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर्स, मैनेज सर्विस प्रोवाइडर्स,
लॉजिस्टिक कंपनीज़, फाइनेंशियल इंस्टीटशंस,
लीगल फर्म्स एंड न्यूमरियस अदर थर्ड
पार्टी वेंडर्स।
मतलब क्योंकि हर एक कंपनी डेली बेसिस पर
पेरोल प्रोवाइडर से बात करती हैं। क्लाउड
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर, मैनेजर सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर, लॉजिस्टिक कंपनीज़, फाइनेंसियल
इंस्टीट्यूशन, लीगल फर्म्स या कोई भी
दूसरी जो थर्ड पार्टी वेंडरर्स के साथ काम
करती ही करती है। हर एक कंपनी में कॉमन
चीज है। एंड एंप्लाइजज़ बिकम अक्यूस्टम। यह
थोड़ा सा मैं प्रोनाउंस नहीं कर पा रहा। टू
रिसीविंग रूटीन कम्युनिकेशन फ्रॉम दी
ट्रस्टेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन मेकिंग देम एन
इफेक्टिव फाउंडेशन फॉर रियलिस्टिक
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस असेसमेंट मतलब यह है
कि
अब डेली ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इन सब से डील करती
है तो उनके जो एंप्लाइजज़ हैं वहां पर जो
एंप्लई काम करते हैं ठीक है
उनकी क्योंकि एक तो अब डेली बेसिस पर उनके
साथ क्या हो रहा है डील करते हैं तो मतलब
उनके उनके लिए वो ट्रस्टेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
हैं। तो जो एंप्लाइज हैं इन ट्रस्टेड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से रेगुलेशन रेगुलर
कम्युनिकेशन करते हैं और कम्युनिकेशन कर
करके उनको आदत पड़ चुकी है। वो आदि हो
चुके हैं इनके। वो इन पर भरोसा करते हैं।
इन पर आंख बंद करके भरोसा करते हैं
इंटरेस्टेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पर। वो इनके आदि
हो चुके हैं कम्युनिकेशन करके। उनके लिए
नॉर्मल चीज है। इसलिए जब आप अटैक करोगे
इनके साइड से तो उनको समझ में नहीं आएगा
क्योंकि उनके लिए एक डेली कम्युनिकेशन है।
एक नॉर्मल कम्युनिकेशन
एक नॉर्मल कम्युनिकेशन से। नाउ चलो मैं एक
एग्जांपल समझाता हूं। फॉर एग्जांपल्स
मान लो यू परफॉर्म ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
एंड डिस्कवर दैट द टारगेट कंपनी आउटसोर्स
देयर एचआर पे रोल सॉफ्टवेयर टू ए थर्ड
पार्टी वेंडर्स। मान लो कि आपने ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस किया हो सेंट परफॉर्म किया।
आपको पता चला जो आपकी जो टारगेट कंपनी है
वह अपने एचआर पे रोओल सॉफ्टवेयर सॉफ्टवेयर
के लिए मतलब जो सैलरी स्लिप है उसको
मेंटेन करने के लिए मैसेज करने के लिए
ईमेल करने के लिए किसी थर्ड पार्टी वेंडर
को आउटसोर्स करती है फॉर एग्जांपल पे डाटा
सॉल्यूशन
ठीक है और आपको क्या पता चला ड्यूरिंग
ओसेंट उनका स्टैंडर्ड ईमेल सिंटेक्स भी
पता चल गया वो क्या यूज करते हैं फर्स्ट
डॉट लास्ट
डोमेन टारगेट company वो ये फॉर्मेट यूज
करती है। अब आपके पास क्या है? आपको क्या
पता है? थर्ड पार्टी वेंडर सोर्स किसका
यूज़ करते हैं? पे रोल के लिए यूज़ करते
हैं? पे डाटा सॉल्यूशन। ईमेल सिंटेक्स
आपको पता चल गया। अब एक बार आपको किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का अगर ईमेल फॉर्मेट समझ में
आ गया। ठीक है? तो उसके बिहाफ पर स्पोफिंग
करना बहुत आसान हो जाता है। उसके बिहाफ पर
स्पोफिंग करना बहुत आसान हो जाता है।
इसलिए वंस यू अंडरस्टैंड द ईमेल फॉर्मेट
योर अटैक डिजाइन बिकम्स एक्सट्रीमली इजी।
अब अगर आप सोचोगे इस पर अगर थोड़ा सा
दिमाग लगाओगे थोड़ा सा सोचोगे जोर डालोगे
तो आपको समझ में आएगा कि जो आपका अटैक
डिजाइन है वो काफी आसान हो गया। अटैक करने
आपको जो प्री टेक्स्टिंग करनी है, जो आपको
वेपनाइजेशन करना है, वह काफी आसान हो गया।
आप आपके लिए काफी आसान हो गया। आप क्या
करोगे? यू बाय ए फेक डोमेन दैट लुक्स
सिमिलर टू द रियल पे रोल वेंडर डोमेन। आप
क्या करोगे? एक फेक डोमेन खरीदोगे जो
बिल्कुल जो यह है ना पे डाटा सॉल्यूशन
वाला बिल्कुल उसका हूबहू दिखने वाला डोमेन
खरीदोगे आप। उसके बाद क्या करोगे? उसके
बाद आपने क्या किया? सारे एंप्लई को एक
ईमेल भेज दिया। ईमेल में क्या लिखा? डियर
एंप्लॉय योर पे स्लिप फॉर दिस मंथ हैज़ बीन
जनरेटेड। प्लीज क्लिक द लिंक बिलो एंड
वेरीफाई यूजिंग योर कॉर्पोरेट कॉर्पोरेट
कॉर्पोरेट लॉगिन क्रेडेंशियल्स। मतलब हमने
आपके लिए मंथली जो पे रोल था पे स्लिप थी
वो जनरेट कर दीजिए कर दिया है। एक बार एक
काम कर लीजिए। आप वेरीफाई कर लीजिए। आप
अपनी जो कंपनी के लॉगिन क्रेडेंशियल्स है
वह एंटर करके अब क्या होगा? एंप्लई इसके
ऊपर ट्रस्ट करते हैं। एंप्लई को पता है कि
उनकी जो कंपनी है इसी वेंडर को यूज करती
है किन के लिए? पे रोल के लिए। तो इसलिए
क्या करेगा? एंप्लई बिना सोचे समझे उस पर
क्लिक कर देगा। क्योंकि एंप्लई को पता है
यह वही कंपनी है। यह वही वेंडर है जो इनकी
कंपनी के अंदर काम करते हैं। इनकी कंपनी
इस पर ट्रस्ट करती है। और इसी को बोलते
हैं हम वेंडर बेस्ड प्रीटेक्स्टिंग। इसी
को बोलते हैं हम वेंडर बेस्ड
प्रीटेक्स्टिंग। क्योंकि अभी आपने जो रूप
धारण किया आपने जो मुखौटा पहना वह किसका
पहना? एक वेंडर का मुखौटा पहना। ना कोई
आईटी एडमिन। इसीलिए मैं बोलता हूं आपकी
इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार पर आपकी पोसेंट के
आधार पर आपकी रिकॉन के आधार पर आपकी
प्रीक्शन जो प्री टेक्स्टिंग है वो हमेशा
डिजाइन होगी प्री टेक्स्टिंग कभी भी फिक्स
नहीं होगी और जब उसने क्या किया
क्रेडेंशियल एंटर किए आपके पास वैलिड
यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड आ गए आप क्या कर सकते
हो लॉगिन कर सकते हो आप क्या कर सकते हो
लॉगिन कर सकते हो आप लॉग इन कर सकते हो
समझ में आ गया यहां तक क्लियर है एवरीवन
यहां तक क्लियर है
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
चलिए फिर अभी हम बात करते हैं एक ऑपरेशनल
सिक्योरिटी टिप देता हूं आपको ऑपरेशन
सिक्योरिटी टिप है आपके लिए। बिल्कुल
ध्यान में रखना। टिप यह है कि जब एक बार
आपने कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन कर लिया।
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन करने के बाद आप जितना
चाहे उतना ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस कलेक्ट कर
सकते हो टारगेट के बारे में। पर हमेशा एक
बात याद रखना कि आपको हमेशा जो टाइम बजट
है ना उसको ध्यान में रखना है। टाइम बजट
क्या है? मैं आपको बताता हूं। टाइम इज
मोस्ट वैल्यूुएबल रिसोर्सेज। कैसे? फॉर
एग्जांपल द क्लाइंट हैज़ गिवन यू 40 हावर्स
इन टोटल। कहने का मतलब क्या है कि फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर क्लाइंट ने आपको टोटल 40
घंटे दिए हैं यह पेन टेस्टिंग कंप्लीट
करने के लिए तो आपको किसी एंप्लई के
Instagram प्रोफाइल के बारे को स्क्रॉल कर
करके और उसमें 12 से 14 घंटे वेस्ट नहीं
करने हैं। कि आपने क्या किया? 40 घंटे
मिले हैं। किसके लिए?
पेन टेस्टिंग कंप्लीट करने के लिए। और 12
से 14 घंटे आपने सब क्या किया? एंप्लई की
प्रोफाइल सोशल मीडिया प्रोफाइल को स्क्रॉल
कर करके उसको रिसर्च करने में ही वेस्ट कर
दिए। आपको ऐसा नहीं करना है। रिस्पेक्ट
योर टाइम। आपको जो टाइम अलॉट हुआ है, जो
टाइम बजट आपको मिला है, उसको ध्यान में
रखते हुए आपका ओसेंट परफॉर्म होगा।
पता चला 40 में 30 घंटे आप ओसेंट परफॉर्म
कर रहे हो लास्ट के 10 घंटे में आप और फिर
भी आपको कुछ नहीं मिला।
नहीं मिला तो नहीं मिला बिकॉज़ टाइम इज
वेरी लेस।
तो आपकी स्ट्रेटजी, आपके टेक्निक्स, आपकी
टैक्टिस उस टाइम बजट पर डिफाइंड होगी पेन
टेस्टिंग में। एक और चीज नॉट एववरी टारगेट
इज इजी। हर बार टारगेट आसान नहीं होता।
कैसे? सम टारगेट्स आर एक्सट्रीमली
स्मार्ट। देयर ऑपरेशन सिक्योरिटी इज सो
स्ट्रांग दैट दे डिड नॉट यूज सोशल मीडिया
एट ऑल। कुछ टारगेट इतने ज्यादा स्मार्ट
होते हैं। उनकी जो ऑपरेशन सिक्योरिटी है,
इतनी ज्यादा स्ट्रांग होती हैं कि वह सोशल
मीडिया यूज़ नहीं करते।
वो सोशल मीडिया का यूज ही नहीं करते। और
इवन वॉर्स इससे भी बदतर दे डेलीबेटली पुट
फेक और मिसलीडिंग इंफॉर्मेशन ऑन द इंटरनेट
टू मिसलीड हैकर्स या
इससे भी खतरनाक वह लोग होते हैं जो
जानबूझकर इंटरनेट पर कोई झूठी या
मिसलीडिंग इंफॉर्मेशन डालते हैं। ताकि जो
हैकर्स हैं
वह गुमराह हो जाए। वह भटक जाए। एंड इस
प्रोसेस को कहा जाता है साइबर वर्ल्ड में
डिसइफेशन एंड डिसेप्शन। डीएनडी क्या बोला
जाता है? डीएन डी डिसइफेशन एंड डिसेप्शन
इसीलिए कहते हैं कि नेवर ट्रस्ट योर
फर्स्ट ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस सोर्स
ब्लाइंडली। कभी भी जो आपको ओसेंट मिली है
उस पर डायरेक्ट ब्लाइंडली ट्रस्ट मत करना।
सिर्फ उसी के बेस पर आपको असेंट मिलती गई
और आपने प्री टेक्स्ट डिजाइन कर दिया उसके
बेस पर प्री टेक्स्ट डिजाइन मत करना हमेशा
एक चीज ध्यान रखना है एक्सपेक्ट डिसेप्शन
हम ऑलवेज अस्यूम द इंफॉर्मेशन यू फाइंड
कैन बी मैनपुलेटेड फैब्रिकेटेड कंप्लीटली
फॉल्स हमेशा आपको ध्यान में रखना है हमेशा
आपको अस्यूम करना है कि जो आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है वह गलत भी हो सकती है
मैनपुलेटेड भी हो सकती है फैब्रिकेटेड भी
हो सकती है हमेशा उसको क्रॉस वेरीफाई करना
है। एवरीथिंग वेरीफाई इंडिपेंडेंट सोर्स
से उसके बाद कोरिलेट एंड एनालाइज। उस हर
एक इंफॉर्मेशन को अदर प्लेटफार्म से जो
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है अदर टूल से जो उसको
हमेशा कोरिलेट करना है। एनालाइज करना है।
उसके बाद फाइनल जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिलेगी
कोरिलेट करने के बाद जो आपके पास वैलिड
इंफॉर्मेशन होगी उसके बेस पर आपको क्या
करना है? एक स्मार्टली एथिकली प्री
टेक्स्ट डिजाइन करना है। इसलिए याद रखिए
गुड हैकर्स फाइंड इंफॉर्मेशन। ग्रेट
हैकर्स फाइंड द ट्रुथ। एक कहावत है जो
यहां पर लिखी हुई है वो सच बात है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड
अंडरस्टुड टिल नाउ? अभी तक क्लियर है?
देखिए अगर आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हो लाइव
क्लास में किसी भी कारण से नहीं आ पाते तो
जब मैं पूछता हूं कि आपको सारी चीजें समझ
में आ रही है या नहीं आ रही है तो आप इसका
आंसर कमेंट बॉक्स में भी कर सकते हो
अदरवाइज मेरी तरफ से मुझे लगता है कि जो
देख भी रहे हैं वह 5 टू 10 मिनट के लिए
आते हैं देखकर चले जाते हैं पता नहीं उनको
समझ में आता है या नहीं आता है
क्योंकि आप लोग अगर आंसर नहीं कर
तो मेरे को तो क्या है मैं जस्ट आऊंगा
स्लाइड ओपन करूंगा और सामने का कंटेंट
पढूंगा और निकल जाऊंगा
जिसको अच्छा लगेगा वह देखेगा जिसको नॉलेज
चाहिए वह देखेगा और जिसको फिर भी कहीं पर
इंस्टट्यूट में जाके और पैसे वेस्ट करने
का शौक है और यहां पर फ्री में कोई
इंटरेस्ट नहीं है तो मोस्ट वेलकम गाइस कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
मेरा कुछ नहीं जाता। आप लोगों का बहुत कुछ
जाता है इसमें।
नाउ इसके बाद बात करते हैं फज़ थ्री डिज़
एंड अप्रूवल जिसको हम बोलते हैं
वेपनाइजिंग ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस। वंस यू
हैव गैदर्ड सफिशिएंट ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
ड्यूरिंग द रिकॉर्न फेस द नेक्स्ट स्टेप
इज डिज़ एंड अप्रूवल। मतलब यह है कि जब
आपके पास अच्छा खासा ओसेंट डाटा आ जाए तो
आप आते हो फिर नेक्स्ट स्टेज पर। नेक्स्ट
स्टेज कौन सा है आपका? फेज थ्री डिजाइन
एंड अप्रूवल।
यहां पर क्या करते हो? दिस इज द स्टेज
वेयर रॉ इंटेलिजेंस इज ट्रांसफॉर्म्ड इनू
ए केयरफुली प्लांट एंड रियलिस्टिक सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग सिनेरियो। यह वही स्टेज है
जहां पर आपकी जो रॉ इंटेलिजेंस थी, आपको
जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिली, उसको क्या किया जाता
है? रियल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग सिनेरियोज़ में
प्लान किया जाता है, प्रोटेक्स्ट किया
जाता है। उसके बारे में डिसीजन लिया जाता
है। उसको डिजाइन किया जाता है। द
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्टेड ड्यूरिंग रिक
रिकनेसेंस इज नो लगर व्यूड एज आइसोलेटेड
डेटा पॉइंट। इंस्टेड इट इज एनालाइज्ड
कोरिलेटेड एंड यूज्ड टू बिल्ड ए क्रेडिबल
प्रीटेक्स्ट दैट अलायंस वि द टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस डेली बिजनेस ऑपरेशंस।
मेरे कहने का मतलब क्या है? यहां आप उस रो
डाटा को एनालाइज करते हो, उसको वेपनाइज
करते हो और उसके बेस पर एक सॉलिड
प्रीटेक्स्ट में उसको कन्वर्ट करते हो। एक
सॉलिड प्रीक्स्ट में कन्वर्ट करते हो और
वो उसको सॉलिड प्रिटेक्स्ट जब कन्वर्ट
करते हो तो ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस के जो डेली
बिजनेस ऑपरेशंस है उसी के फॉर्म में उनको
क्या करते हो? कन्वर्ट करते हो, प्रोटेक्ट
करते हो। उसी के फॉर्म में उनकी जो
डिजाइनिंग वेपनाइजिंग या उसी के फॉर्म में
क्या करते हो उस इंफॉर्मेशन को या उसकी
कहानी बनाते हो ताकि कंपनी आप पर विश्वास
करे
ओके तो नेक्स्ट
वन प्रिंसिपल दैट एव्री एथिकल हैकर रेड
टीम ऑपरेटर्स मस्ट अंडरस्टुड
अब
एक बात हमेशा याद रखना एज एन एथिकल हैकर
और एज ए रेट ऑपरेटर आपको यह बात समझनी
होगी जो अभी मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं।
ध्यान से सुनना। द सक्सेस ऑफ एन एथिकल
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट इज नॉट मेजर्ड
बाय हाउ लॉन्ग यू रिमेन अनडिटेक्टेड।
एक एथिकल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट की
सक्सेस इस बात पर डिपेंड नहीं करती कि आप
कितनी देर तक अनडिटेक्टेड रहने वाले हो उस
नेटवर्क में या उसमें कंप्लीटली
अनडिटेक्टेड हो। इट इज मेजर्ड बाय हाउ
इफेक्टिवली दी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन डिटेक्ट्स एंड
रिस्पांस टू द सिमुलेटेड अटैक। एक सक्सेस
एथिकल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट की जो सक्सेस
है वह इस बात पर डिपेंड करती है कि जब यह
सिमुलेटेड अटैक परफॉर्म किया जा रहा है
कितनी इफेक्टिवली कितनी आसानी से कितनी
जल्दी कितने प्रोएक्टिवली जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
को डिटेक्ट और रिसोंड करती है। यही इस
सिमुलेटेड अटैक की सक्सेस है ना कि छिपके
रहने में सक्सेस है। नहीं समझ में आया
होगा। मेरे कहने का मतलब क्या है? ऐज़ एन
एथिकल हैकर हमारा अल्टीमेट सक्सेस
क्राइटेरिया
यह है कि हमें
हम पकड़े जाएं।
अगेन बोल रहा हूं एज एन एथिकल हैकर
हमारा जो अल्टीमेट सक्सेस क्राइटेरिया यह
होगा कि हम ड्यूरिंग अटैक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
प्रडार में या ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के शॉक टीम के
द्वारा या उनके एंप्लॉय के द्वारा पकड़े
जाए।
अब मुझे पता है कि लोग सोच रहे होंगे सर
क्या बहके बहकी बातें कर रहे हो? क्या
बकवास बातें कर रहे हो आप? आपका दिमाग तो
सही है ना? मतलब आप बोल क्या रहे हो? आपको
पता है सर पकड़े जाएं।
सारा खेल दुनिया में बिना पकड़ने का और आप
सर हमें पकड़वा रहे हो। मतलब कि सर आप
बोला ठीक-ठाक तो हो? या कुछ प्रॉब्लम है
तो बोला सर क्लास को कल करते हैं। यह क्या
बातें कर रहे हो आप?
बट जो मैं बोल रहा हूं वो सही बोल रहा
हूं।
क्योंकि आप सोच रहे होंगे सर अगर अटैक फेल
हो गए तो मतलब पकड़े गए तो फेल हो गया
क्योंकि हैकर का काम क्या है छिप के
निकलना होता है राइट
राइट ना एवरीवन हैकर का काम क्या होता है
छिप के निकलना पकड़े गए तो अटैक फेल है और
सर आप तो पता नहीं क्या बकवास पढ़ा रहे हो
आज तो क्या लेके आ गया सर ये आज हमें क्या
सिखा रहे हो आपका मेरे ख्याल से कि शायद
प्रॉब्लम है आप मतलब कि गलत पढ़ा रहे हो
आज
यस यही है ना फिर से मैं बोलता हूं यही
बात एज एन एथिकल हैकर हमारा अल्टीमेट
सक्सेस क्या है कि ड्यूरिंग अटैक हम पकड़े
जाएं
फिर बोलोगे बोला सर नहीं आपका हो गया
दिमाग खराब आज का करो सेशन एंड और थोड़ा
सा आप सब सोच के आओ राइट
राइट मैं बैक की वैकी बातें कर रहा हूं ना
बे काम की
बताइए
जगत गुरु जी linuक्स 35 फिनकम
अमन बताइए ये
नहीं समझ में आया होगा। बस अब फ्यूजी उड़
गए। आज तो आपने क्या बोल दिया? आप हैकिंग
सिखा रहे हो। हमें पकड़वा रहे हो।
ट्विस्ट यही है।
कोई रिसोंड नहीं कर रहा।
नहीं समझे? समझोगे।
यही फर्क होता है किसी एक मिशियस ब्लैक
हेट हैकर्स और एक एथिकल रेटिमर में। दैट
इज द डिफरेंस।
क्या डिफरेंस होता है कि एक जो मिलेशियस
ब्लैक हेड हैकर्स होता है वो क्या करता
है? ए रियल साइबर क्रिमिनल मेजर सक्सेस
बाय रिमेनिंग इनविज़िबल फॉर ए लॉन्ग फ़ एज
लॉन्ग एज पॉसिबल। देयर ऑब्जेक्टिव इज टू
स्टिल इंफॉर्मेशन मेंटेन पर्सिस्टेंस लिव
विदाउट बीइंग डिटेक्टेड। कोई एक जो रियल
साइबर क्रिमिनल्स होता है वो अपनी सक्सेस
को मेजर करता है कि वो नेटवर्क के अंदर
जितना हो सके उतना इनविज़िबल रहे,
अनडिटेक्टेड रहे ताकि वह उस इंफॉर्मेशन को
चुरा सके। अपना पर्सिस्टेंस मेंटेन रखें
और चुपचाप उस नेटवर्क से निकल जाए। यह
मेंटालिटी होती है एक ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स
की, एक बैड माइंड हैकर्स की या एक
मिलिशियस ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स की।
इसके अपोजिट जो एथिकल रेटिमस जिसकी बात हम
कर रहे हैं जो हम बनने जा रहे हैं। आवर
ऑब्जेक्टिव इज टू डिटरमाइन वेदर द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पीपल प्रोसेस एंड सिक्योरिटी
टेक्नोलॉजीस कैन आइडेंटिफाई रिपोर्ट एंड
कंटेन ए रियलिस्टिक अटैक बिफोर इट
रिजल्ट्स इन ए सिग्निफिकेंट डैमेज। हमारा
ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या है? बिल्कुल उसके अपोजिट
है। एक ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स के अपोजिट। ब्लैक
हट हैकर्स का ऑब्जेक्टिव यह है कि वो
नेटवर्क में जितनी देर रहे अनडिटेक्टेड
रहे, इनविज़िबल रहे और अपना काम करके निकल
जाए। एज ए एथिकल रेटिमस हमारा काम है यह
हमारा जो ऑब्जेक्टिव है, यह है कि
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर जो लोग काम कर रहे
हैं, जो टेक्नोलॉजी यूज़ हो रही है, जो
उनकी प्रोसेस है, वह हमारे अटैक को
आइडेंटिफाई करें, रिपोर्ट करें।
ठीक है? और कितना जल्दी उसको डैमेज को वो
रोक सकती है, यह मेजर करना हमारा काम है
एज ए एथिकल रेड टिमर। मतलब उनका रिस्पांस
कितना फास्ट है वो मेजर करना हमारा काम है
एज ए रेटिमर। अंडरस्टुड?
एज ए रेड टीमर्स। अभी समझ में आया? यह
हमारा काम है। और इस चीज को बोलते हैं रेड
टीम पैराडॉक्स। द रेड टीम पैराडॉक्स बोलते
हैं जो हम करते हैं एज एन एथिकल रेड टीमर।
यह टर्म सर्च कर लेना मिल जाएगा। ठीक है?
अब नहीं समझ में आया होगा। इस पे और आगे
बात करेंगे और चर्चा करेंगे ताकि आपको समझ
में आ जाएगा कि मैंने ऐसा क्यों बोला कि
जब हम सिमुलेटेड अटैक परफॉर्म करेंगे तो
हम पकड़े जाएं।
हम पकड़े जाएं। चलो इफ आवर सिमुलेशन गोज
कंप्लीटली अननोटिस्ड द क्लाइंट रिसीव ए
रिपोर्ट स्टेटिंग दैट द असेसमेंट सक्सीड
बट द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन हैज़ लर्न वेरी लिटिल
अबाउट इट्स एक्चुअल डिफेंस कैपेबिलिटीज।
अगर हम
ड्यूरिंग टेस्टिंग बिना पकड़ के पकड़े
निकल गए। हम किसी के पकड़ में नहीं आए
लाइक ए ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स तो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है तब भी क्या होगा क्लाइंट को एक
पेपर पेपर पर रिपोर्ट मिलेगी ठीक है
मिलेगी रिपोर्ट रिपोर्ट में लिखा होगा
सक्सेसफुल पेन टेस्टिंग सक्सेसफुली हम पेन
टेस्टिंग कर लिया जिससे पढ़कर क्या होंगे
जो वहां के जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन जो क्लाइंट
हैं वह डर जाएंगे घबरा जाएंगे और उनको
उनकी जो डिफेंसिव कैपेबिलिटीज है उनको जो
ट्रेनिंग दी गई है उनके जो सेशन हुए होंगे
ट्रेनिंग सेशन हुए होंगे साइबर से रिलेटेड
डिफेंसिव कैपेबिलिटीज है उनके बारे में
उनको कभी पता ही नहीं चलेगा उनके बारे में
उनको सीखने का मौका ही नहीं मिलेगा उनको
रियल सिमुलेशन कभी नहीं मिलने वाला कि सच
में ऐसा हो गया तो हम कैसे करेंगे बिकॉज़
दे आर टोटली डीमोटिवेटेड बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ आवर
मिस्टेक क्योंकि हम ब्लैक हैटर हैकर्स की
तरह आए और चले गए लेकिन उनको पता ही नहीं
चला। चला हमारा पर्पज क्या है? अभी बताता
हूं।
ऑन द अदर हैंड इफ एन अलर्ट एंप्लॉय
रिपोर्ट द सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी और इफ द
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर डिटेक्ट्स एंड
रिसोंड टू द अटैक ड्यूरिंग द असेसमेंट। द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन गेन समथिंग फार मोर वैलुएबल
देन ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट रिपोर्ट। मतलब
उसके अपोजिट क्या हुआ? अगर वहीं पर आपका
अटैक किसी एक अलर्ट एंप्लई ने पकड़ लिया,
आपकी सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी को आइडेंटिफाई कर
लिया या उनकी जो ब्लू टीम है उसने डिटेक्ट
कर लिया तो उससे उन्हें बहुत कुछ सीखने को
मिलेगा
बजाय एक रिपोर्ट के अलावा। पहले उनको
रिपोर्ट मिल रही थी। अब उनसे बहुत कुछ
सीखने को मिलेगा। क्या सीखने को मिलेगा?
उनका जो ट्रेनिंग लूप है वह कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा। जो उनका रियल ट्रेनिंग लूप है वह
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। एक रियल ट्रेनिंग लूप
क्या है? एंप्लई को मिली फेक रिपोर्ट।
उसने रिपोर्ट किया। रिपोर्ट करके कंपनी
सिक्योर हो गई। एक ट्रेनिंग लूप होता है।
ठीक है? अब ट्रेनिंग लूप होता क्या है? जो
कंप्लीट होने वाला है उस पे डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं। चलिए फिर व्हाट इज ए रियल
ट्रेनिंग लूप?
रियल ट्रेनिंग लूप कंप्लीट मींस द कंपनीज
एंटायर सिक्योरिटी इकोसिस्टम्स पीपल
प्रोसेस एंड टेक्नोलॉजी वर्क टुगेदर
इफेक्टिवली
वर्क टुगेदर इफेक्टिवली रियल ट्रेनिंग लूप
कंप्लीट होने का मतलब है कंपनी का जो
कंपनी का पूरा सिक्योरिटी इकोसिस्टम यानी
उसके जो लोग थे उनकी जो टेक्नोलॉजी थी
उनकी जो प्रोसेस थी काम करने की सारे ने
मिलके एक साथ एक तरीके से काम कर गए। मतलब
उनके जो लोग थे, उनकी जो ट्रेनिंग थी,
उनकी जो प्रोसेस थी, उनकी जो प्रोसीजर्स
थे, उनकी जो पॉलिसीज थी, उनकी जो
टेक्नोलॉजी थी, सबने मिलके काम किया और
अपने आप को डिफेंड किया। यह सिखाना हमारा
काम था। अभी भी नहीं समझ में आया होगा।
सिनेरियो लेते हैं। एक रियल वर्ल्ड
सिनेरियो से समझते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल
एन एंप्लई रिसीव आवर फेसिंग ईमेल। मान लो
एक एंप्लॉय को हमारी भेजी हुई फेसिंग ईमेल
मिलती है। एंड जिस एंप्लॉय को हमने वो
फेसिंग ईमेल भेजी। उस एंप्लॉय ने अपनी जो
अवेयरनेस ट्रेनिंग थी उसको बहुत ध्यान से
सुना था। बहुत ध्यान से उसको सीखा था। और
उसमें सीखने के बाद उसने क्या किया कि उस
ईमेल ईमेल के जो सेंडर एड्रेस था उसको चेक
किया। उस ईमेल को सस्पेक्ट समझा।
सस्पेक्टेड ईमेल कंसीडर किया। और उसके बाद
किया क्या किया उसने? विदाउट क्लिकिंग द
लिंक दे सस्पेक्ट इट इज ए मिलिशियस एंड
क्लिक द रिपोर्ट फिशिंग बटन। उसने उस ईमेल
को सेंडर एड्रेस चेक करने के बाद उसको लगा
सस्िशियस मेल है। उसने उसको क्या किया?
बिना क्लिक किए उसको एज ए फेसिंग रिपोर्ट
कर दिया। उस एंप्लॉय ने उस मेल को फेसिंग
रिपोर्ट डिक्लेअ कर दिया कि यह फेसिंग मेल
है। अपने स्क्रीन पर रिपोर्ट फेसिंग बटन
पर क्लिक कर दिया कि यह मेल सही नहीं है
भाई। वेरीफाई कर लिया क्योंकि उसने अपनी
ट्रेनिंग को ध्यान से सुना था। ठीक है? अब
यहीं से स्टार्ट होता है ट्रेनिंग लूप। जो
ट्रेनिंग लूप की जिसकी बात कर रहा हूं
यहां से ट्रेनिंग लूप स्टार्ट होता है।
ट्रेनिंग लूप कैसे स्टार्ट हुआ? सबसे पहले
ट्रेनिंग लूप में आता है द ह्यूमन एक्शन
लॉग। द एंप्लॉय चूजेस टू बी अलर्ट इंस्टेड
ऑफ़ मेकिंग ए मिस्टेक। मतलब एंप्लई ने डरने
या गलती करने की जगह क्या किया? अलर्ट
होकर उस ईमेल को रिपोर्ट किया। बिकॉज़ उसकी
ट्रेनिंग अच्छी हुई थी। एंड द टेक्नोलॉजी
की बात आते हैं। द रिपोर्ट हिट द
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर डैशबोर्ड। जो
एसआईएम टूल्स हैं जो शॉक डैशबोर्ड है उस
पे क्या करती है? वह ईएल तुरंत क्या करती
है? कंपनी के सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर के
डैशबोर्ड पे हिट करती है। एंड शॉक टूल्स
एनालाइज द ईमेल एंड सी इट वाज़ डिलीवर टू
500 एंप्लई। जो शॉक एनालिस्ट थे जो शॉक
टीम थी सेम टाइम उस ईमेल को क्या करती है
एनालाइज करती है उसका टूल एनालाइज करते
हैं और देखते हैं कि यह सेम ईमेल इस टाइप
की ईमेल हमारे 500 एंप्लई को और भेजी गई
है यह थी टेक्नोलॉजी तीसरी चीज क्या आई उस
लूप में इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस जिसको हम बोल
सकते हैं प्रोसेस प्रोसेस में क्या हुआ जो
सॉफ्ट टीम थी जो ब्लू टीम थी उसने उस पर
एक्शन लिया एक्शन लेने के बाद क्या किया
उन्होंने दे ब्लॉक द मिलीस लिंक अक्रॉस द
एंटायर नेटवर्क। उसने क्या किया? उस जो
मिलेशियस लिंक था उसको पूरे नेटवर्क में
ब्लॉक कर दिया। एंड आल्सो वन मोर थिंग दे
रिमूव द ईमेल फ्रॉम द इनबॉक्सेस ऑफ द
रिमेनिंग 499 एंप्लॉय। और उन्होंने क्या
किया
कि बाकी जो 499 एंप्लॉय जो जिनके इनबॉक्स
में मेल गई हुई थी वहां से भी उसको हटा
दिया। डिलीट कर दिया।
डिलीट कर दिया। इसलिए व्हेन एन एंप्लई
स्पोर्ट्स एंड रिपोर्ट्स ए सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी एंड द शॉक टीम डिटेक्ट एंड
रिस्पांस इन रियल टाइम। दैट इज व्हेन
ट्रेनिंग इज नो लगर जस्ट ऑन पेपर। अब
बात यह है मैंने प्रोसेस बताई। तीनों ने
एक साथ काम किया। लोग पीपल टेक्नोलॉजी और
प्रोसेस तीनों ने अपना काम किया मिलकर तो
अटैक रोक लिया। तो इसलिए
मेरे कहने का मतलब क्या है कि जो एक
एंप्लई है जब तक वह रियल लाइफ में किसी
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी को नहीं देखेगा वो
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी को देखकर रिपोर्ट नहीं
करेगा और जब तक जो शॉक टीम है अपने रियल
लाइफ एक्सपीरियंस में या रियल रियल टाइम
में उस रिपोर्ट को एनालाइज नहीं करेंगे
ब्लॉक नहीं करेंगे तब तक उनकी जो ट्रेनिंग
हुई थी वो सिर्फ ऑन पेपर ट्रेनिंग हुई थी
प्रैक्टिकल ट्रेनिंग नहीं हुई थी रियल
सिमुलेशन नहीं हुआ था। अभी जो आपने अटैक
परफॉर्म किया और उस अटैक में आपने ऐसा भी
चाहा कि वह डिटेक्ट भी हो जाए और डिटेक्ट
होने के बाद जब उनकी जो ट्रेनिंग लूप
कंप्लीट होता है उससे उनका कॉन्फिडेंस बढ़
गया। उससे उनको पता चल गया कि जो हमने
ट्रेनिंग थी वो सही ट्रेनिंग थी। उनको पता
चल गया किस टाइप की फिशिंग ईमेल आती है।
हम रिपोर्ट करेंगे। शॉप टीम कैसे रिएक्ट
करेगी। शॉप टीम को रिएक्ट करने पता चल गया
हम कितना जल्दी एक्शन ले सकते हैं। कितना
जल्दी हम एक्शन ले सकते हैं। इसलिए व्हेन
दिस एंटायर डिफेंसिव चेन इज सक्सेसफुली
एक्टिवेटेड ड्यूरिंग आवर ऑथराइज असेसमेंट
वी कैन कॉन्फिडेंटली से दी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग लूप हैज़ बीन
कंप्लीटेड। जैसा मैंने अभी बताया जब हमने
वह टेस्ट परफॉर्म किया और अगर यह डिफेंसिव
चेन एक्टिवेट होती है तो आपका जो
सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग लूप है वह कंप्लीट हो
गया।
ठीक है? वह कंप्लीट हो गया। नेक्स्ट एज ए
रिजल्ट इफ ए रियल थ्रेट एक्टर लॉन्चेस ए
सिमिलर अटैक इन द फ्यूचर दी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
विल नॉट बी रिस्पोंडिंग फॉर वेरी फर्स्ट
टाइम। इट्स एंप्लॉय सिक्योरिटी
टेक्नोलॉजीस एंड इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम
विल ऑलरेडी बी फमिलियर वि द रिक्वायर्ड
एक्शन एंड डिसीजन मेकिंग प्रोसेस। अब
फ्यूचर में कभी भी इस टाइप का अटैक हुआ तो
उस टाइम पर जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है उसको ऐसा
नहीं लगेगा कि वो फर्स्ट टाइम ऐसा अटैक
देख रहे हैं। नहीं क्योंकि इस टाइप का
सिमुलेशन वो परफॉर्म कर चुके हैं। अब उनके
जो एंप्लॉय हैं, उनकी जो सिक्योरिटी
टेक्नोलॉजीज़ है, उनकी जो इंसिडेंट
रिस्पांस टीम है, वह तैयार हैं। इस टाइप
का अटैक होगा। सेम टाइम वह अपना डिसीजन
मेकिंग पावर यूज़ करेंगे, डिसीजन लेंगे।
उसको अटैक को ब्लॉक करेंगे और उस अटैक से
बाहर आएंगे। और हमारा काम क्या है? यही
उनको ट्रेन करना है। यही उनको सिखाना है।
दिस इज व्हाई रेड टीम एक्सरसाइजज़ एंड सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग असेसमेंट आर कंडक्टेड। यही वो
कारण है जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में
रेड टीम एक्सरसाइज और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
असेसमेंट कंडक्ट की जाती है। क्या करने के
लिए? उनकी मसल्स मेमोरी को डेवलप करने के
लिए। ताकि जब इस टाइप की सिचुएशन आए तो वह
सेम टाइम इस सिचुएशन को रिकॉग्नाइज कर
पाएं। उसको रिपोर्ट करें, इन्वेस्टिगेट
करें और जल्दी से जल्दी कॉन्फिडेंटली उसको
स्टॉप कर पाएं। दैट इज द मेन गोल ऑफ आवर
पेंटेस्टिंग रियल चमुलेशन। यह हमारा मेन
गोल होता है किसी उसका। ठीक है? क्योंकि
हमारा काम यह नहीं है कि कंपनी को नीचा
दिखाना, उसके एंप्लई को नीचा दिखाना नहीं
है। हमारा काम है उनको रियल वर्ल्ड थ्रेट
के लिए तैयार करना। हमारा काम बिल्कुल भी
नहीं है। उनको नीचा दिखाएं, वो करें। ऐसा
बिल्कुल हमारा काम नहीं है। अब बात होगी
यह थी। लेकिन अब यह जो सिमुलेशन की बात हो
रही है, यह तो मैंने आपको बताया कि
क्या-क्या किस पर्पस से हम कर रहे हैं।
लेकिन हमारा फज़ थ्री है डिजाइनिंग एंड
अप्रूवल। तो, हमें क्या करना है? जब हमने
प्री टेक्स्ट डिफाइन कर लिया, चूज़ कर
लिया, क्या-क्या करने वाले हैं? उसके बाद
हमें क्या करना है? अप्रूवल चाहिए। अटैक
ल्च करने से पहले सिमुलेशन पहले हम
अप्रूवल चाहेंगे। जैसे कि मैंने लास्ट
क्लासेस में भी बताया था। बिफोर एनी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कैंपेन इज ल्च
एव्री प्लान एक्टिविटी मस्ट रिसीव फॉर्मल
क्लाइंट अप्रूवल।
हमारे पास एक फॉर्मल क्लाइंट अप्रूवल होना
ही चाहिए। दी असेसमेंट टीम मीट विद द
क्लाइंट डेजिग्नेटेड पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट
एंड शेयरर्ड एवरीथिंग।
एवरीथिंग मतलब एवरीथिंग। ऑल मतलब यह है कि
हम क्या करते हैं कि हमें अटैक ल्च करने
से पहले अपने पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट से पास
जाना है और जितने भी हमारे अप्रूव्ड
प्रीटेक्स्ट हैं स्प फोन नंबर्स हैं
टारगेटेड ईमेल एड्रेसेस हैं एग्जीक्यूशन
का एग्जैक्ट नहीं अप्रोप्रियट जैसा मैंने
बताया था हफ्ते में कभी भी नेक्स्ट वीक
में कभी भी इस टाइप का टाइम विंडो आपको
शेयर करना है सब कुछ उसके साथ शेयर करना
है इससे क्या होता है। आपकी जो
ट्रांसपेरेंसी है वह बनी रहेगी और आपको
बताना है कि हम क्या करने वाले हैं। आई एम
सेंडिंग अ फेसिंग ईमेल टू चेक हाउ मेनी
पीपल क्लिक ऑन द लिंक। मैं यह चेक करना
चाहता हूं कि कितने लोग उस पर क्लिक करने
या फिर आई विल अटेम्प्ट टू डिप्लॉय ए
रिवर्स सेल ड्रॉपर ऑन द सिस्टम। या फिर
मैं क्या करूंगा? एक रिवर्स सेल ड्रॉप
करूंगा। डस एवरीवन नो व्हाट इज़ व्हाट डू
आई मीन बाय रिवर्स सेल?
रिवर्स सेल का मतलब पता है सबको?
रिवर्स सेल ड्रॉपर क्या होता है? मैं बता
देता हूं। ए रिवर्स सेल ड्रॉपर इज ए
मिलसियस पेलोड और स्क्रिप्ट दैट ऑन
एग्जीक्यूशन बायपास द फायर वाल फ्रॉम
इनसाइड एंड क्रिएट ए रिमोट आउटबड कनेक्शन
टू द अटैकर मशीन गिविंग देम फुल एक्सेस।
मतलब यह एक ऐसे मलशियस पेलोड या स्क्रिप्ट
होती है जो टारगेट सिस्टम पर एग्जीक्यूट
होती है। फायर वाल को अंदर से बायपास करती
है और हैकर की मशीन पर एक आउटबड कनेक्शन
क्रिएट करती है। रिवर्स कनेक्शन भेजती है।
क्योंकि जो फायर वाल्स होती हैं वो
इनकमिंग ट्रैफिक को तो ब्लॉक कर देती हैं।
लेकिन ज्यादातर जो आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक होता
है अंदर से बाहर जाने वाला जो ट्रैफिक
होता है वह ज्यादातर अलाउ होता है। उसको
ब्लॉक नहीं किया जाता और जब एक बार
अटैकर्स को कनेक्शन मिल जाता है तो सोचली
बूम मतलब पूरा एक्सेस मिल गया बिना फायर
वाल को एक्सप्लइट किए। तो ये थे तीन फेज
ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल।
पहला कौन सा था? स्कोप फेज। दूसरा कौन सा
था? कौन सा था? फेज टू रिकॉर्न जिसको हम
बोल सकते हैं ओसेंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग।
थर्ड वन कौन सा था आपका? डिजाइन एंड
अप्रूवल
वेपनाइजेशन ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस की जो
इंफॉर्मेशन उसको वेपनाइज करना है। अब उसके
बाद चार पांच छ सात चार फेज को हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में पढ़ेंगे और मोस्ट प्रोबब्ली वो
क्लास क्या होगी? टुमारो होगी। मोस्ट
प्रोबेब्ली आपकी अनाउंसमेंट मिल जाएगी कल
10:00 बजे तक।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
नो नो नो नो इन रिवर्स द रिक्वेस्ट गोज
फ्रॉम हां यस राइट राइट राइट तो सबको समझ
में आया गाइस
क्लास में कुछ सीखने को मिला
सब कुछ सीखने को मिला
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
और जल्दी कुछ बहुत ही अच्छी चीज़ आने वाली
है। एक शो या कुछ अच्छा आने वाला है जो
इनफेटिव होगा। बहुत ज्यादा इनेटिव
जिस पे किसी ने बात नहीं की होगी उस पे हम
बात करने वाले हैं। और आई होप आप लोग उसको
बहुत
प्यार करने वाले हो। बहुत लव करने वाले
हो। आई आई थिंक कि मैं चाहता हूं कि आप
उसको नहीं सबके पास फैला दो। क्योंकि वो
ऐसी चीज होगी जो शायद उस पे कोई
यह मायने नहीं रखता कि कोई एज ग्रुप कि
यही देख सकता है, यही नहीं देख सकता। घर
में कोई भी देख सकता है, कोई भी सुन सकता
है। कोई भी टेक चाहे वह टेक हो, नॉन टेक
हो, आईटी हो, नॉन आईटी हो वह सबके लिए।
ओके।
थैंक यू अगर आपको ऐसा लगता है तो
और शायद इनफेटिव से ज्यादा है बिकॉज़ यह
कोर्स मैंने बनाया है आप लोगों के लिए
बहुत सारे कोर्स को निचोड़ के एक कोर्स
बनाया है जहां पर आपके एक्सपेक्टेशन से
बहुत ज्यादा है क्योंकि कोई सिंगल कोर्स
नहीं है कि मैं जल्दी से पढ़ा के निकल
जाऊं। बहुत सारे कोर्स इसमें मर्ज हुए
हैं। बहुत सारे कोर्स का निचोड़ है। इसमें
जब यह कंप्लीट होगा ना जिस दिन उस दिन आप
लोग खुद ही देख पाओगे कि हमने कितना कुछ
कवर किया है। बिकॉज़ मैं इसके एक्सेल शीट
भी डिजाइन कर रहा हूं साथ के साथ सिलेबस
की कि जो हमने कवर किया है। आपको पता
चलेगा कि आपने क्या सीखा है। इतना
कोर्स कहीं नहीं मिलने वाला। बहुत सारे
कोर्स इसमें मर्ज हैं। जिनको आप वैल्यू
देते हो ना कि ये इतने पढ़ाता है या इसकी
ये पॉपुलरिटी है। सब इसमें मर्ज हैं। सब
के सब
जिसका सब्सक्रिप्शन लाखों का है वो भी
मर्ज है इसमें।
सब कुछ मर्ज है इसमें।
यार मैं मैं सोच रहा हूं आप लोगों के लिए
नोट्स कैसे प्रोवाइड करूं। बिकॉज़ सब लोग
ऐप पर भी नहीं है। तो कुछ अल्टरनेटिव मुझे
बताओ ना मैं जहां पर अपलोड कर सकता हूं आप
लोगों के लिए।
कहां कर सकता हूं? क्योंकि मैं tlegram
नहीं चलाता लिटरली और मैं चलाना नहीं
चाहता।
उधर कर सकते हैं अपलोड। मैं आई एम रेडी टू
गिव माय नोट्स। नो प्रॉब्लम।
बिकॉज़ वन ड्राइव या जी ड्राइव को हम क्या
कर सकते हैं ना वह नहीं कर सकते कि वहां
पर नोट्स नहीं दे सकते क्योंकि मैं एक्सेस
ब्लॉक हो जाएगा क्योंकि आप लोग की
रिक्वेस्ट बहुत ज्यादा आएगी
Google मीट में
कोई अल्टरनेट ढूंढो ना
जहां पर आपको नोट्स मैं प्रोवाइड कर सकूं।
ऐप इज करेक्ट बट सारे स्टूडेंट ऐप पर नहीं
है।
जल्दी हम इसके प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं। इसकी चिंता मत करो कि मुझे लगता
है कि मैंने ऑलरेडी पढ़ाया भी है ओसेंट के
जो हमारी सीरीज है बट थोड़ी बहुत मैं
रिपीट कर दूंगा नो इशू ताकि
या यह सही है।
तो एक मैं एक दिन एक काम कर देता हूं। ऐप
का फिर से अनाउंस कर देता हूं। फिर से बता
देता हूं ताकि वहां पर आके आप नोट्स
कलेक्ट कर लो। ओके
फिर
यार आपका नाम तो बता दो ओरिजिनल यार मेरे
को नाम बता दिया करो। आई एम योर ट्रेनर
यार।
दीपशिख
ओके दीपशिख आई एम मैं सही सही बोल रहा
हूं।
दीपशिख
आप लड़के हो लड़की
दीप शिख
आर यू गर्ल
ओके आई एम सॉरी मुझे नहीं पूछना चाहिए था
बट
मैं गलत नाम नहीं लेना चाहता था थैंक यू
वेरी मच नाम बताने के लिए
चलिए फिर हम एक काम करते हैं। सेशन को एंड
करते हैं और
कल मिलते हैं। मोस्ट प्रोबे्ली कल सेशन
आपका होगा। कंटिन्यू करेंगे। ओके? चलिए
फिर बाय-ब एंड थैंक यू एवरीवन एंड सी यू
फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन। गुड नाइट एवरीवन। बाय-ब
गुड नाइट एवरीवन।